captain buzz flies are playing by using
the audio jack in the audio jack alone
this means that you can put your phone
into a plane throw it away and with
almost no other electronics on board
the phone alone can control the plane so
by using the audio jack what we can do
is put a cable directly from the jack
into the plane's servos and we generate
a special type of music called pulse
width modulation pulse width modulation
is basically generating a horrible
buzzing sounds which is where the name
captain buzz comes from these square
wave pulses have been interpreted by the
servos as traditional commands so one of
the initial problems that we had with
captain buzz was that while she flew as
she flew badly and would struggle even
to fly straight and level so I was
tasked with trying to reduce the lag in
order to make captain bars fly much
better so that she returned from a
pregnant duck into a fighter pilot now
one of the things that we found was that
a lot of the lag in the phone is not to
much caused by receiving sensors but by
the fact that Android has not been made
to fly planes around so funnily enough
when Android was built and they decided
to add audio music to Android one of the
key concerns was that when people
listened to Taylor Swift they don't want
the beats being dropped so Android
actually has a policy whereby every app
when you send a audio data it uses a
technique called buffering to make sure
that all of the data is collected and
stored by the operating system for a bit
before it's actually played out loud
this is great for music but when you're
trying to fly a plane you don't want
this lag and you don't necessarily mind
if some of your square wave signals get
lost you just want to make sure that the
time between them being generated and
being played out if the audio jack is as
small as possible so the delay is
largely controlled by the manufacturer
of the handset we found that some
handsets were having a delay of around
750 milliseconds others were having a
delay of around 250 milliseconds ideally
to fly a plane well you want to be
around 120 milliseconds as a minimum now
one of the techniques that we employed
to reduce the delay was by rewriting a
bunch of the audio code so it no longer
acts as a traditional app but it's
written using the C programming language
this means that we can avoid all of the
buffering policies which are put in by
the manufacturers and directly generate
sounds which are sent out to the
server's so one of the things that we
found
is when writing all of the audio
generation software NC we have a trade
off because we want to make sure that
when we generate all these square waves
they align well to the natural buffers
inside the audio controllers built into
the hardware so we've actually made some
changes to pulse width modulation the
buffers inside the phone are aligned in
a multiple of 18 so one change that
we've made is rather than generating
pulse width modulation signals which
repeat every 20 milliseconds ours repeat
every 18 milliseconds so we can fill a
hardware buffer which means that we can
reduce the lag even further I have the
Android wear watch because we've used
the Android operating system in order to
write our app we can then write a very
small amount of code in order to get the
app also work on the watch which gives
some some really cool features which you
just don't see on other ways of making
drones as well as the time we also have
the current flight plan so you can see
at the moment that's straight and level
because the flight plan is empty however
what we can do is swipe to the side and
choose between various commands so new
left-hand turns and right-hand turns at
the moment the communication is all
performed over Bluetooth the problem
with this is that the range of Bluetooth
is quite low now the current watches
that are on the market most of them only
have a Bluetooth link but more of the
ones which are coming out such as the
Apple watch and some of the newer
Android wear watches have Wi-Fi as well
now the range of Wi-Fi is much larger
than Bluetooth so around 100 meters so
we can connect two buzzers she's flying
around much more easily as Wi-Fi becomes
more prevalent
so initially she's trying to fly
straight and level which is the default
commands when we haven't entered
anything for instance we can perform a
left-hand turn and you just tap the
button and she executes a left-hand turn
similarly we can do a right-hand turn
and then the worst flight surfaces will
move now if we scroll back you can see
now that she's banking right for for
five seconds then left for five seconds
and she just keeps repeating this flight
plan so in the air would be banking left
and banking right a cool feature which
I've added is actually the ability to
send commands to captain buzz so if we
go to say command buzz fly heading 1-0-0
for 10 seconds and then it understands
the commands I've sent sends it to the
plane
and then if we go back to the flight
plan you can see she's now flying
heading 100 degrees for ten seconds and
then after that we'll go back to doing
the left-hand turns and then right-hand
turns now one of the other nice things
that we can do is get buzzed to perform
aerobatics in particular buzz is now
able to fly loop the loops really well
so we can even come on these from a
watch buzz fly in a loop and as it
processes the command then when it's
finished its current thing you can see
the servos have just pulled back so buzz
is trying to pull back like this why /
and then she comes out of the loop and
tries to fly onto her heading well as
two days ago is due this smartphone
integration the next thing that we need
to fly the SmartWatch integration system
which we've not tested yet but I'd
really like to try some novel new GPS
free navigation technologies so we can
do some cool stuff with Wi-Fi we can
plug a software-defined radio into the
bottom of the smartphone and use radio
signals that are GPS base to navigate
which would be quite cool lots of work
on that that's been done in the past but
not on a smartphone on a drone fully
autonomous drone that costs less than a
hundred pounds to make and also vision
distant core stuff we could do with
OpenCV the graphical processes on the
smartphone and processing the optical
flow of the the scene underneath so gps
free navigation for their drone is my
next aim lots of government agencies are
coming cost and they say we want our
system to be assessed by your experts
how secure is here shoot Lee spent more
on security and well okay so how many
experts Rick the arts only two channels
coming out of the smartphone but with an
even more complicated square wave going
on and this board of op-amps we can
unpick four channels so that